pixar's brilliant coming of age movie
turning red is packed with easter eggs
and deep cut references to other pixar
and disney classics like luca toy story
coco and moolam plus the upcoming light
year among many others yipikai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'm
revealing the very best easter eggs and
crucial details you might have missed in
turning red some mild spoilers ahead so
take care
the pizza planet truck is one of pixar's
most popular easter eggs and debuted in
the studio's first feature toy story in
turning red watch carefully as red panda
melind charges through the streets of
toronto on her way to the four town
concerts speeding past a parked pizza
planet truck with its distinctive white
and red rocket and there's more easter
eggs to the famous animated food brand
including numerous pizza planet boxes
scattered around tyler's house during
his birthday party and an ad for pizza
planet at the skydome stadium where the
four town concert takes place
the luxo ball also makes its appearance
at tyler's birthday party you can see
the iconic yellow red and blue ball
floating in a swimming pool the ball
first appeared in the short film luxo
junior and interestingly in may's room
there's a desk lamp with a similar
design to the famous lamp from that
short
another recurring pixar easter egg a113
appears on screen for just a split
second during the stadium scene when
mei's dad uses a chalk machine to draw a
circle around his wife's enormous red
panda look very closely at the chalker
because it's a professional model a113
and there's another a113 on the four
town tickets in the credits the presence
of a113 and pixar films is a tribute to
the callots classroom where many of the
studio's animators studied
when maelyn finds herself suddenly
crushing on a boy at school you'll
notice his t-shirt reads escapola which
is a deep cut reference to coco and the
heavy metal band of the same name who
performed in the land of the dead's
battle of the bands escapola means
shoulder blade in spanish making it a
perfect name for a band of dead bony
musicians and speaking of bones kevin
from up makes an appearance as a
skeleton in the school classroom in
another scene you can see some mexican
papel picado decorations like we also
saw in coco another nice detail in this
scene is how mei raises her paws in the
air while standing up similar to how
real-life red pandas will rise upon
their back legs when they're scared in
order to look bigger
every pixar movie includes an easter egg
to the next one on the studio schedule
and next up is lightyear buzz's origin
story in turning red melon's friend
miriam is an avid skater and if you look
at her skateboard very closely you can
spot a sticker of socks buzz's robotic
cat companion in light year hello
i am socks your personal companion robot
turning red tips its hat to luca another
coming-of-age pixar story where melin is
fantasizing about devon and draws him as
a merman in her notebook a reference to
the dual human and sea monster nature of
characters like luca and alberto may
also has visions of devon as a fish
during her nightmare when she first
transforms into a red panda in lucca the
turning red easter egg was craftily
hidden in julia's room via the record
titled four star village the italian
word village means villagers similar to
the word town making the vinyl record a
reference to turning red's boy band 4
town
and there's another fishy pixar easter
egg via the finding nemo sticker on a
stall in the school bathroom
prior to directing turning red domi she
was best known for her short film bow
about a chinese mother living in toronto
and a dumpling that comes to life given
as she says dumplings are a huge staple
in chinese culture it's fitting to find
them repeatedly and turning red are you
hungry um
and there's even a sign for a restaurant
called bao oh and there's also the exact
same chinese decoration on the wall of
maiden's home as there is in she's
oscar-winning short
when ming makes meimei a bowl of
porridge with eggs and a smiley face
it's a little tribute to the happy
porridge mushroom makes for moolan in
the disney animated movie look you get
porridge and it's happy to see you and
actor james hong who plays mr gao in
this movie was also the voice of chifu
in disney's much-loved 90s film
the number of the lee family home is 234
a likely reference to the address of
andy's second house as revealed in toy
story 3. where's home elm street 234 elm
there's an easter egg the pixar short
film pearl in may mae's bedroom via the
little pink ball of yarn with eyes
hanging just above her desk similar to
turning red the theme of pearl is about
learning to accept who you really are
rather than what others want you to be
the rabbit sticker on mainland's
notebook is the bunny from burrow the
pics are short about a young rabbit who
wants to dig the perfect burrow but ends
up embarrassed as she keeps digging into
her neighbor's homes
when we first meet priya she's reading a
romantic fantasy novel called nightfall
the final chapter the book's cover
complete with a vampire feels like a
homage to the twilight saga with the
central couple giving off strong bella
swan and edward cullen vibes fun fact
director xi says that priya and her
deadpan goth-like manner represents how
she and her friends were into vampires
punk rock and emo around the end of
middle school
turning red continues the trend of luca
with a striking and sometimes
exaggerated animation style and she
infused the film with details from anime
so whenever a character gets especially
excited their eyes become super dilated
with sparkles and stars a very popular
effect in anime all of which is intended
to communicate and signal the emotional
rollercoaster of adolescence
this shot and pose of may leaping across
the sky feels like a specific shout out
to the japanese animation the girl who
leapt through time i loved the style of
this shot with maelin set against the
red moon and as she soars through the
air you can also spot a billboard for
air canada with a particularly fitting
tagline for mae in this moment fly with
us
a running joke and theme in turning red
centers around the number four which in
many east asian cultures including china
is frequently viewed as an unlucky
number four is the worst number you know
vivian was due on the fourth but i held
her in until the fifth it might also be
an extra subconscious reason for ming's
dislike of the boy band four town why
are they called fourth town if there are
five of them the gag continues at the
end of the movie when we discover
melin's grandma had to put her panda
spirit in a four-town medallion so
unlucky and notice how her losing hand
consists of an ace and four cards with
the number four
red panda may's reaction to spotting
devon at the daisy mart
is a hat tip to the awooga meme which
drew on tex avery's cartoon red hot
riding hood which features a thirsty
wolf watching a nightclub singer and
intriguingly opposite the convenience
store there's a cafe maymay a play on
ming's nickname for her daughter meimei
but also a visual pun on the word meme
turning red is set in 2002 and there's
some fun naughties references in the
movie such as the jockeyer phone that
mei uses a reference to how nokia phones
dominated the cell phone market in that
period
there's also some wassup graffiti on the
stores in the school bathroom a
reference to the budweiser ad campaign
that ran from 1999 to 2002 and became a
viral sensation
and maelon's flute case has some
stickers referencing trends from around
the turn of the millennium such as the
save the whales campaign and y2k aok
referencing the millennium bug and the
y2k scare
the inspiration for turning red's boy
band is the likes of nsync and
backstreet boys who were particularly
popular at the time the movie set and
whose tracks appeared in the film's
trailers like 4town nsync's name also
includes an unspoken asterix the
all-white outfits worn by fortan during
their concert tour channel the cover of
the backstreet boys album millennium and
possibly take that's everything change's
album while the fictional boy band
angelic look could well have been
influenced by the backstreet boys role
in the apocalyptic comedy this is the
end which featured them in heaven all
dressed in white complete with halos
singing everybody there's a pop culture
reference to marvel comics and movies
where may cries first the symbol a twist
on avengers assemble and of course
marvel is owned by disney and there's a
nod to another franchise now owned by
disney the simpsons via the two red
panda statues who may lin refers to as
bart and lisa outside the ancestral
family temple hey bart
haley said when abby discovers red panda
may her reaction is hilarious you're so
fluffy which really reminds me of
despicable me's agnes and her obsession
with
unicorns it's just fluffy alternately it
could be a nod to this moment in disney
zootopia
hey you can't just touch a sheep's wall
the unicorn sticker on may's flute case
with its multi-coloured mane and tail
could be a little nod to rainbow unicorn
from inside out who joy sadness and bing
bong meet when they visit dream
productions
when ming turns into an enormous red
panda and stomps through the city on the
way to the concert i got some real
godzilla and king kong vibes especially
the scene of her roaring silhouette on a
toronto skyscraper and the way red panda
ming grabs melin in her giant paw is a
nod to the classic moment when king kong
grabs andaro up in his giant hand
there's also a ton of canada's specific
easter eggs and references in the movie
some are easier to spot like toronto cn
tower or this one 200
who do they think they are celine dion
but others are less obvious like this
sign for milk sold in bags or this
student's t-shirt loons unlimited which
is a play on the fact that the common
loon is the provincial bird of ontario
where toronto is located on top of that
the nickname for the canadian dollar is
the looney and the single dollar coin
has a common loon design on the reverse
another canadian symbol you'll see a lot
of in turning red is the maple leaf
however a few are particularly well
hidden such as the maple leaf pattern in
the toque the canadian term for a
knitted hat that may worse to cover up
her red hair there's also a maple leaf
love t-shirt in the background of this
shot and a maple leaf badge on the front
of ming's car which also has a bobble
head mousse on the dashboard in the
aftermath of the destruction of the sky
dome a little blue bird comes into view
the inclusion of this bird next to the
stadium is a sneaky easter egg to the
toronto blue jays baseball team which
plays its home games at the stadium and
a very similar blue jay design appeared
in the pixar tv series dug days set
after the events of up the donuts that
gin isn't allowed to eat at the
breakfast table are tim bits from the
multinational canadian chain tim hortons
no sugar another toronto easter egg you
might have missed is on the sticker in
miriam's locker sk8 stands for skate as
we know she's a skater but yyz is the
airport identification code for the
toronto pearson international airport
which is named after the canadian prime
minister lester b pearson who also lends
his name to may and miriam's school
stores in the movies version of toronto
include the humorously named tchaikovsky
presumably a tea shop punningly named
after the famous classical composer and
there's also d's vintage fashion which
could be named after d from up the
little girl who watched carl's house
float past her window
when the lee family performed the
ceremony to separate the red panda
spirit from may's body mr gao explains
they are opening up a door to the astral
realm for as long as the red moon shines
the astral realm will be open and this
circle
is the door and there's an interesting
parallel here with the astral plane from
seoul an area between the soul world and
earth where moon wind opened up a portal
that sent joe's soul into the body of a
cat and 22 into joe's human body in both
movies this astral realm appears to be a
place where spirits or souls can enter
or depart human bodies which surely
conjures up some interesting
possibilities for pixar theories let me
know any ideas theories or connections
you might have about the two films
if you didn't sit through all the
credits you might have missed the funny
little bonus scene at the very end of
the movie featuring jyn dad dancing in
the basement to a four-town song
you know it does yeah
i absolutely loved turning red so for my
next video i'm doing a deep dive into
all the clues that predicted the ending
of the movie i'll add a link here and in
the description so you can watch it as
soon as it's ready so who's your
favorite character in turning red and if
you spotted any other easter eggs let me
know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this don't forget to leave a
thumbs up and subscribe i really
appreciate it thanks for watching and
see you next time yippee kai movie
lovers